Thanks to CuriosityStream for supporting this
episode! Go to CuriosityStream.com/microcosmos
to start streaming thousands of
documentaries and non fiction TV shows.
We’ve spent most of our journey through the
microcosmos seeking out the organisms that
are too small to see with the human eye.
The bacteria, the ciliates, the tardigrades.
And Part of what makes them so
exciting to find is that they are
so tiny. Every moment we spend with one of
these organisms is a peek into something
exceptional in our experience of the world,
and it’s the result of how much work James,
our master of microscopes, has to put into
hunting down as many microbes as he can.
And sometimes, that effort
requires a lot of persistence.
Take the creature we’re going to
focus on today: the bristle worm.
This has been one of the white whales for our
channel for some time. And as you watch it,
you can perhaps understand
why we have been searching
so hard for it. It’s got the body of a pipe
cleaner with the head of a cartoon dragon.
And maybe you also understand
that just because we’ve been
wanting to find one of these worms, that doesn’t
mean we are guaranteed anything. After all,
one of the things you have to
accept about the microcosmos,
and microbe hunting,
is that it is a big world full of tiny creatures,
and it can take a while to find some of them.
The fact that we are showing you
one of those bristle worms right now
spoils the twist we would usually build
into, but, surprise, we found a bristle worm!
The real twist is that this was
not the first bristleworm we found.
This was the first bristle worm we found.
Twenty centimeters of segments and bristles
climbing up the side of a tank before
burrowing back beneath the sand.
Unfortunately, that’s just about all the video
we got of that bristle worm.
James spent so much time trying to
find this bristle worm again that he
started to feel a connection to it. So
he decided to give it a name: Gunther.
James spent hours trying to catch it
without hurting the worm. But Gunther
has hundreds of appendages
that can grab onto sand,
and James didn’t want to accidentally
snap the worm in half with his tweezers.
So instead of showing all the features of Gunther
that we wanted to show, we’re going to show clips
of this bristle worm instead because it kind
of resembles Gunther, except a lot tinier.
Gunther is hopefully still somewhere in that
tank, living a nice life in the burrow it dug
for itself. But it’s hard to know exactly where
in the tank Gunther made its home because it
would only show activity in the dark. The moment
James tried to turn the lights on and watch the
worm in motion, it would vanish again under the
sand. And as it became harder and harder to find,
James kept hoping that one day, something
would bring another bristle worm to him.
And then, one day, James received a
package from a coral farm containing
sediments and other things that might
contain some interesting organisms.
We talked about some of those organisms
that James found in our last episode.
But in addition to all of those
organisms, James found several
species of his long sought after bristle worm.
Bristle worms are also known as polychaetes,
and they’re part of the segmented
worm phylum known as Annelids.
The name “polychaete” translates in Greek to
“many hairs.” Those stiff hairs are called
setae, and for most polychaetes,
they’re attached to paddle-like
appendages called the parapodia that
branch off each segment of the worm.
Our giant friend Gunther most likely
belongs to the order Eunicida,
but its microscopic look-alike is more unknown
to us. But we can imagine that it spends its
life crawling around the sand and feeding on
algae, or whatever else it can take a bite out of.
You can see this one moving its mouth in
slow motion, like a weird pair of pincers
inside clamping down on something, and the
movement is even more dramatic in full speed.
This probably looks like a bunch of
tiny individual orange worms tangled
together. But it is, in fact, a worm belonging
to the genus Cirratulus that can get to around
12 centimeters in length. And along with
its distinctive color, the worm is easy
to spot in wet sandy mud because of those
threads you see waving across your screen.
Some of these threads are tentacles,
but others are actually gills.
And in the water, those threads seem to float
serenely. But this effect is lost on land.
In a paper from the beginning of the 20th
century titled “Notes on the Ecology of
Cirratulus tentaculatus,” the author
wrote, “When withdrawn from the mud
Cirratulus presents an exceeding
limp and bedraggled appearance.”
This worm has a more imposing appearance
but also a funnier name. It belongs to the
terebellid order, but it’s known as a spaghetti
worm. These tropical worms live in sand,
building tubes out of gravel and limestone to
live in. Their tentacles spill out from the tube,
sometimes extending as far as a meter to gather
building materials and food for the worm.
To reproduce, spaghetti worms will release their
eggs and sperm into the water, but only at night
and sometimes even without other males or females
around. They seem to do this on a lunar cycle,
with a limited two week window for these
gametes to release and find each other. That
seems like an extraordinarily chance-y way to
reproduce, but it seems to work for this worm.
These are the bristle worms we were able
to find from our coral farm samples. And
so it seems like our hunt for
this white whale might be over.
Except, the more we’ve been reading about
bristle worms, the more we wish we could find
even more. Because these are an animal whose
existence seems designed to inspire lists
of fun facts and bizarre trivia. There
are thousands of species of polychaetes,
and they all seem to have something
remarkable or weird about them.
Some spend their lives in tubes that stick up
from the sand, using their parapodia to paddle
water through the burrow. Others have managed
to carve out lives near hydrothermal vents.
Some sound like they’re straight out of a horror
novel, growing up to ten feet long or dining on
the bones of decomposing animals. And some
even have eyes on both ends of their bodies.
So knowing that all of these
different species are out there,
how could we ever end our quest
for the bristle worm?
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
This episode has been brought to you by Curiosity
Stream, a subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and non­fiction
TV shows from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including award winning exclusives & originals.
They cover topics like history, nature, science,
food, technology, travel, and more!
And to balance out all of the creepy
crawlies you’ve been watching throughout this
episode, this week we’re going to recommend
checking out The Science of Cute on Curiosity
Stream. Not only will you get to see a bunch
of super cute puppies, but you’ll also learn
about the domestication of dogs and how their
behavior and anatomy has changed over time to
make them just the cute little things ever.
You can stream CuriosityStream’s library,
including their collections of curated programs
handpicked by their experts, to any
device for viewing anytime, anywhere,
and if you go to curiositystream.com/microcosmos
and use the code “Microcosmos” to sign up,
it will only cost you $14.99 for an entire year!
The people whose names are on your screen right
now, they are our Patreon patrons. We are so happy
and excited to be able to continue our search
of the microcosmos doing weird things like
writing to coral companies and having them send us
samples. I think that’s just the beginning of some
of the cool stuff we can do, and these patrons
are the reason that we can do it. So thank you
so much to all of them, and if you want to become
a patron you can go to Patreon.com/JounreytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our
master of microscopes, James Weiss,
and why wouldn’t you, check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram,
and if you want to see more from us, there is
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.